ils sont aussi présents nos panélistes
du vendredi je les présente michael
fortissimo françoise boivin gilles
duceppe et brian gallant bonsoir à vous
inscrire merci à toi d'être présent et
là ça s'annonce assez corsé aujourd'hui
parce que c'en était toute une journée
toute une semaine aussi avec ces deux
débats celui d'hier qui marquent
l'actualité puis à quel point ça va
changer la tournure de la campagne pour
ce qu'il reste à dire une dizaine de
jours ça reste à voir mais on va
commencer par un retour sur ce seul
débat en anglais ce qui a retenu
l'attention ce sont les toutes premières
minutes le préambule et la question de
la modératrice shashi cruel qui
présidente de l'institut angus reid
question qu'elle adressait à yves
françois blanchet du bloc québécois on
va entendre cette question la réaction
de monsieur blanchet et les réactions
que ça suscite tour de table ensuite
à
québec
j'ai été très surpris par le genre d'
amalgame
qui a été mis là dedans et j'ai trouvé
ça absolument
inacceptable les québécois ne sont pas
racistes hier soir le style de certaines
questions étaient injustes leur racisme
systémique et la discrimination
systémique existe à travers le pays dans
chaque province et chaque territoire si
monsieur trudeau
monsieur o toole
monsieur singh
était sincère il ne serait pas intervenu
un rattrapage en france et ce matin il
serait intervenu en anglais hier soir
pendant le débat il ya beaucoup de
choses dans ces extraits beaucoup de
pistes de questions et de réponses
possibles et le fond et la forme en tout
premier lieu j'aimerais entendre gilles
duceppe là dessus monsieur duceppe dit
toi plus comment on réagit en entendant
cette question tout départ et je
voudrais ça m'a choqué et ça s'est
produit en 2019 également une
journaliste avait posé la même question
alto rage et appuyé par
le consortium moi je pense qu'elle va
toi niveau de québec dachine y est celle
qu'on appelait mme la modératrice qui
est en fait une provocatrice qui repose
la question deuxièmement le comité
éditorial ça c'est tous les journalistes
qui participent l'eau des bords plus la
provocatrice et des représentants de six
bicici living road aux news qui ont
rédigé la question et troisième niveaux
québec d'achat le consortium qui ne l'a
pas rédigée mais qu'il a vu sinon à
prouver
il faut le faire et suite à cela la
réaction des chefs
quand monsieur trudeau nous ils forment
ne me permettait pas de réagir il y
avait des points de presse après
monsieur trudeau a commencé en
félicitant les jo fernandez à dakar et à
fait licite mais aussi nos meilleurs
joueurs de tennis mais comment se
fait-il que le temps de faire ça et
parvenir sa question ni monsieur automne
et monsieur saint denis madame pose
c'est parce qu'il voulait pas dire en
anglais ce qu'ils ont tenté qu'ils ont
dit aujourd'hui monsieur autour et
monsieur trudeau plus clairement madame
paule absolument à propre monsieur cinq
patinoires en haut je trouve ça
déplorable on peut pas imaginer qu'une
telle chose se soit produite en français
mais là ça deux fois des deux derniers
démons anglais qu'une telle chose se
produit mais de gros bonnets dénonce
aujourd'hui
inacceptables tout simplement michael
fortier ben moi aussi je trouve ça je
trouve la question déplacée
surtout
considérant le rôle que je vois la
personne qui a posé la question au delà
de ça je vois pas de coffre complot
comme je pense pas que c'est quelque
chose premier halo non pas un complot
gels mais ce que tu insinues c'est que
hier un travail d équipe oui les déçus
du poste il a affirmé aujourd'hui
c'était rédigé par ses nerfs ça
fonctionne je parle aux journalistes qui
étaient sur le panel en français ils
m'ont dit on régissent nos questions
ensemble c'est ce qu'ils ont fait cg
calcium et le consortium
sinon a pu vite tout au moins et vu la
question et l'a permise oui je vais
jusqu'au train les y compris je suis
également parce que je pense que ce
n'était pas à elle de poser cette
question je pense que
indifférent d'opinion sur ces sujets il
y en existe au canada il sur d'autres
sujets et c'est exactement pas à elle
avec le ton que le prix d'ailleurs même
temps d'ailleurs que j'ai trouvé
déplorable même la veille en français
certains des journalistes qui ont posé
des questions à l'air enragé et valeurs
très négatif par rapport au chef mais
qu'un autre chef est posé cette question
là ça m'aurait moins ébranlé mais ce que
j ai mis de monsieur blanchet ses fruits
sa réponse et sa répartie surtout en
entrée de jeu je les trouvais très bon
dans sa réponse c'est pas quelqu'un pour
lequel j'ai beaucoup d'atomes crochus
mais j'ai trouvé que hier soir durant
ces quelques minutes
juste une petite note là simplement pour
un souci de l'information importante de
souci d'équilibré la la modératrice en
question s'est défendu aujourd'hui en
disant que le qualificatif
discriminatoire mais il revenait aussi
où il faisait aussi référence un
jugement de la cour supérieure du québec
en ce qui concerne une de ces deux loups
loi là je la paraphrase ici pour suivre
au mieux fait de le dire et de
paraphraser de cette façon des choses
que vous venez rire serez été plus
habile de sa part de le dire ainsi
françoise boivin votre opinion là dessus
moi comme mes collègues j'ai trouvé le
début très intéressant c'était agressif
remarquez qu'on toute la journée il
devait de perversion ne parle que de ça
et c'était 5 minutes sur les deux heures
de débat ça mal commencé quand j'ai
entendu ça j'ai aussi apprécié la
réponse des françois blanchet après ça
ça continue avec chacun des chefs avec
des tons un peu agressant et aujourd'hui
compte tenu de la polémique je suis
aller m'amuser à les voir le mandat de
la commission des débats qui est que de
l'air d'un organe déconnecté là mais
c'est quand même présidé par l'ancien
gouverneur général john eliot c'est pas
des deux pays qui sont dans cette
commission là et leur mandat est clair
alexis c'est d'informer le public ces de
de rendre la politique les plateformes
électorales au niveau des
téléspectateurs pour que les gens
puissent comprendre c'est pas
nécessairement la meilleure formule qui
a été prise hier soir que la soirée
précédente compte tenu de la façon que
ça fonctionnait alors ça fait déraper
quelles seront les conséquences dans les
journées à venir
tout le monde a été un petit peu victime
de la méthode peut être moins - à fleur
de peau comme nous on obtient des fois
l'épiderme plus sensibles jugé rien
appris du canada anglais le contenu de
leur position sur la loi 21 puis la loi
96 c'est tout des choses qu'on entend
parler régulièrement mais ça faisait
cinq archers aux oreilles de se partir
un débat de cette façon d' mais est-ce
que ça écorche les oreilles et à
l'extérieur du québec gallant dans
quelle mesure ça peut avoir ou ça a un
écho qui pourraient durable au sein d'un
électorat en dehors du québec
je suis entièrement d'accord
assemat déplacer deux jambes allaient à
monsieur blanchet du québec et seulement
du québec selon moi il y a raciste
systémique partout au pays partout au
travers probablement pas un expert mais
à travers du monde occidental alors il
ya des défis mais mais la façon donc
c'était formulé comme vous avez dit
alexis ayant donné une excuse
aujourd'hui mais y aurait pu faire ces
qualifications là pour mieux expliquer
pourquoi la question il était comme ça
et qu'est ce que moi j'ai vraiment aussi
trouver des places et c'était la
première question à jack meeting et vous
êtes tellement populaire
les gens vous aiment tellement mail à
votre plateforme
c'était comme vraiment drôle au début du
débat et les progrès du débat non
directement m'a complètement bouleversé
je savais plus quoi m'attendre
avait participé et chaque fois qu'elle
participe elle je me disais mais qu'est
ce qui se passe vous avez cinq secondes
monsieur trudeau vous avez 5 secondes
pour départ et pour l'étude des
commentaires
oui la grande question françoise vous
l'évoquez ses banques un seul impact sur
la campagne sur la dizaine de jours qui
restent à keith avantage ou pourquoi
pourtant on se dit ça fait l'ontario ça
va jouer mais là où québec ce ça prend
beaucoup de place quelle quelle est
votre analyse du simple messieurs
legault je pense bien résumé situation
aujourd'hui il a demandé à tous les
chefs de dénoncer ce qui s'est passé
hier soir on verra bien s'ils ne feront
et de déclarer que la loi 21 et 96 ne
sont pas des lois discriminatoires
moi j'attends les réponses j'ai hâte de
voir ça et s'engage et conséquemment n'a
pas les contester en ga de devoir
de voir ces répondre et c'est sûr que
les québécois sont pas très heureux de
ce qui s'est passé est cela étant dit et
on se dit jours encore on va attendre
monsieur legault asine clairement qu'ils
souhaitent un gouvernement minoritaire
conservateur mais si tel est le cas ça
prend parti pour l'appuyer il ne sera
pas l'erreur ni believe est rompu de
façon unie et ça ce pôle est une paix
des non plus il reste que le bloc qui
devrait avoir l'aval ans de pouvoir s'il
veut qu'une telle chose soit possible or
c'est là que ça se joue oui et là on a
vu monsieur o'toole et monsieur trudeau
défendre le québec le québec n'est pas
raciste c'est là la réaction vient de
nous être acheminés de l'association sic
mondiale qui dénonce les sorties de
monsieur o'toole et trudeau les cycles
d'origine au canada c'est une part
importante de l'électorat à vancouver à
toronto ou ailleurs c'est là où ça
brasse toutes sortes de choses michael
fortier alors au québec puis ce qui
s'est passé hier soir va donner beaucoup
d'oxygène à monsieur blanchet blanche et
il est excellent sur le territoire
identitaire mais si vous regardez son
programme politique
on parle de saine alimentation les vous
parlez entendu parler de h'cicène
alimentation de respect envers les
malades et là on revient sur un terrain
où il excelle ci peut garder ce sujet à
l'avant scène pour la prochaine semaine
grand avantage à lui à l'extérieur du
québec
fera voir jusqu'à quel point ça va jouer
aussi fort qu'au québec celui qui risque
d'avoir un avantage parce qu'il défend
toujours les valeurs dites canadienne
c'est peut-être monsieur trudeau mais il
va falloir qu'il fasse attention si le
dit quelque chose a qu'un blues il
pourra pas dire le contraire à
kamouraska je cois
[Musique]
salir et salir atteint vous disiez de
françois bès allure et rap effectivement
alors signé sur une pente un peu
glissante monsieur trudeau il aimerait
bien se draper de son drapeau canadien
de défenseur des droits et libertés
défenseurs d'aider des deux lames du
multiculturalisme canadien et tout ça
mais il ya vraiment besoin de ces de ses
sièges au québec parce que il ya des
batailles absolument épique qui sont en
venir en colombie britannique en ontario
alors il peut pas se permettre ce qui
concerne ce qu'il a et même d'améliorer
ou au québec pour les pertes qu'il va
subir peut-être en atlantique brian sera
nous dire tantôt alors ça c'est un jeu
dangereux pour lui monsieur o'toole vont
continuer sa campagne de la même façon
qu il le fait depuis le départ avec les
enjeux qui dans le fond dans le
quotidien du reste du canada mais aussi
des québécois n'est pas d'hier on n'est
pas niée zones sont aussi on vit là la
hausse des coûts de vie de la vie et
tout ça alors il va continuer sa
campagne là dessus monsieur blanchet
faudra voir moi j'ai vieilli j'ai vécu
la campagne 2015 j'ai vu comment je
gagne à 100% jusqu'à deux semaines du
scrutin avec le niqab l'histoire d'une
câble qui est sorti comme une petite
chose peut devenir une grosse lune une
étincelle peut devenir un feu de forêt
assez rapidement alors on verra on verra
comment le blog voile joué mr jeu
dangereux je pense que monsieur blanc
jade as tu eu la bonne attitude le
premier ministe legault au fait sa
sortie lille au point été aussi virulent
à l'endroit des autres chefs on a senti
qu'il y avait encore son appui pour les
conservateurs mais il a bien dit qu'il
était là pour défendre la nation
québécoise et on veut on verra ça reste
ça en reste là où si on décide de tout
simplement exploiter ce filon et se voit
ça m'horripile autant que ce qui pose la
question comme madame comme shashi hier
soir ça m'horripile autant ceux qui
profitent de certaines choses comme ça
pour essayer d' attiser d'aider des feux
de foyer qui ne font que divisée qui
n'est absolument pas la cause de la
nation québécoise et de nos valeurs
communes entre une chose est certaine et
notre discussion en ce moment le prouve
sa occulte d'autres enjeux de cette
campagne et qui ont été abordés dans le
débat hier gallant j'aimerais vous
entendre nous entendre là dessus est ce
que c'est quelque chose que vous
déplorez
bah oui absolument je veux dire c'est
encore une fois la modératrice ou bien
le processus qui a été entamée à faire
en sorte que ce soit ça devenu une
histoire mais c'est un peu intéressant
par même que c'est vraiment de quoi tu
fais bouger au québec un suisse et un
débat en anglais tandis que moi je
sentant que le débat d'hier soir pour un
des partis a vraiment été un gain
transport disons à l'extérieur du québec
ont convaincu que ça va bouger des votes
de façon sérieuse si on peut dire que
c'est ni les inégalités ou ou 40 46 ont
vu
mes et mais normalement un débat où il
ya pas vraiment de gagnant c'est bon
pour le banc manceau alors évidemment
pas plus a dit rideau mais tu peux aussi
faire l'argument que s'il ya pas eu de
gaza est dessus et celles qui sont en
avance dans les sondages alors peut-être
à aider monsieur autour selon moi la
personne qui avait vraiment besoin de
gagner
lors de cette campagne c'était jo 2006
je pense que les gens vont commencer à
se questionner est-ce qu'on peut encore
pour une paix des on aime bien il est
populaire comme reste à 10 mai mais si
on fait ça est ce qu'on risque d'avoir
un gouvernement conservateur minoritaire
alors ça reste à voir mais je pense y
avait besoin de gagner le débat hier
soir il ya bien qu'informé le vainqueur
prenons la balle au bond je vous soumets
un peu la question où l'angle de la
discussion qui est initié par brian
gilles duceppe vainqueur hier est-ce
qu'il y en a un réellement selon vous
moi je pense que tous on jouait la
partie qu'il devait jouer monsieur
trudeau a été très critiqué
et en ce sens là ils étaient moins bons
que dans les deux autres débats monsieur
de l'archet s'attendait absolument pas
une telle chose est certaine d'être là
vainqueurs par la force des choses parce
que ça profite de plus meyer a pas
souhaité s il ya personne qui souhaite
intel est autre chose en politique on
est en démocratie il ne faut pas tomber
dans ce piège
monsieur singh est très gentille et
l'année sur le coeur mais on ne sait pas
ce projet quels sont ils monsieur autour
de toujours des pleins pour dès qu'ils
nous disent que des plaines mal d'années
et madame paule je pense que elle veut
une barre d'ailleurs la peur mais pas
michael fratty après moi c'est pas
tellement le débat tiers qui je suis
d'accord avec bryan qui a probablement
pas fait bouger les grilles mais je
pense qu'il faut se poser la question
n'a déjà parlé de yves marie vachette
forte blanchette et la prochaine semaine
oui donc le lierre soir risque de
l'aider mais il ya monsieur ou tout
aussi qu'ils pensent peut-être que
l'intervention de monsieur legault
d'hyères oui hier en faveur wiley de
mais je pense que je voudrais que le
cocktail de cette intervention avec ce
qui s'est passé hier soir je l' ai vécu
avec des collègues de toronto à qui je
parlais aujourd'hui c'est que d'abord
les gens se demandaient pourquoi ce que
monsieur legault soudainement appuyé
monsieur au tournant pour des gens qui
suivent pas la politique comme nous il y
avait une interrogation est ce que c'est
encore une fois le québec qui tentaient
de prendre le contrôle
indirectement de la situation à ottawa
mais avec ce qui s'est passé hier soir
en plus avec monsieur blanchette
monsieur o'toole risque de se faire
poser beaucoup de questions dans la
prochaine semaine sur sept 7 ans jeudi
dans d'identité au québec parce qu'ils
leur ce lien avec monsieur
monsieur indirectement avec monsieur
legault donc il va devoir se prononcer
sur ces enjeux identitaires il va devoir
être beaucoup plus précis qu'il ne l'a
été jusqu'à maintenant et il risque
d'être coincé je pense dans la prochaine
semaine pour toi qui soit habile du
moins là pour éviter des pièges par sait
ce qui l'attend je pense en raison de
ces deux événements qui sont passés à
quelques heures d'un glauque il noyé des
amalgames qui se font dans certains
esprits à ce sujet là françoise est ce
que ça peut jouer effectivement en la
défaveur de monsieur tout
peut-être mais ce que je perçois surtout
sur le terrain car je parle aux gens
c'est comment ce sentiment on en parle
peut-être moins ce soir mais que les
gens sont énormément frustré d'être en
campagne électorale présentement
chanteur
j'étais au vote par anticipation alexis
les lignes et c'était pouvant table il
manque de personnel nous autres dans mon
côté on avait reçu une carte une carte
d'électeur avec aucune adresse où aller
voter se marquer à déterminer ça
ressemble beaucoup des fois pour qui on
veut voter et quand je parle avec les
gens je les replacer par le site
internet n'est-ce pas tout le monde qui
va réussir à avoir ce réflexe qui vont
il y en a qui vont se décourager les
gens qui me disaient essentiellement
c'est que ben on comprend pourquoi ces
deux mêmes parce qu'on est en pandémie
puis on n'aurait pas dû est en élection
alors beaucoup de gens cristallise sur
le gouvernement en place que déclencher
qui voulait sa majorité on oublie ça
aussi à c'était comme ça pour porter
cette campagne électorale on était à dix
jours du bois les gens sont encore
frustré y attendait de voir reçu autour
lyon la bénédiction de monsieur legault
ça se travaille dans la dans la taille
des gens alors on verra pour le souhait
alors qu'on dit au tout début que cette
frustration à l'être passagère on verra
donc pour la suite et sur la
participation électorale bengals en
terminant votre mot de la fin
premièrement pour monsieur legault je
peux convaincu qu'un politicien qui
encourage les gens de portée d'une telle
façon lors d'une élection d'un autre
niveau de gouvernement est vraiment une
différence de plus l'euro j'ai trouvé ça
assez étrange
d'explication qui a donné de dire que
selon lui les libéraux le npd sont en
jeu je pense pas que ça fonctionne allez
les gens connaissent très bien monsieur
trudeau les gens connaissent le meeting
aussi en raison du fait sa deuxième
campagne à la fin de la journée par
essayer de faire peur aux gens ce qu un
peu de sang frais il faut pouvoir ça
fonctionne juste des gens connaissent
pas la personne
ici brian g le michael et françoise
merci infiniment pour votre
participation aux débats
à leur voix